[Music]
[Applause]
yeah leave it the other name for this
piece is George Washington is an [ __ ]
Yeah right he's a creep that guy you'll
see what I'm talking this tells you is
how they make their money
for example Marco Rubio I didn't know
this but 40% senatorial salary 20% of
his money comes from speaking fees 40%
of his money comes from gap kids model
he's a little guy little guys as well
SIA did you know this SIA 20% from music
sales 40% concert appearances and 40%
renting out hair to car washes it's in
there and pushes it around Bernie
Sanders check this out 30% Senators
salary 10% investments 60% winning bets
that he can name any deli soup of the
day Shia LaBeouf
Shia LaBeouf 50% suing guys who punch
them in bars 50% suing guys who punch
them in restaurants
Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell this
surprised me 42% being Senate Majority
Leader 30% family trust
28% rent from tenant living in his chin
for yeah that's right the alien from the
alien movies this is interesting
99% playing the alien in the Alien
movies sure 1% playing saxophone at the
baked potato jazz club M night Shyamalan
that's right 60% residuals for movies
39% directing fees 1% gotcha this pie
charts been dead the whole time Donald
Trump Donald Trump 50% huge things 25%
great things
10% really great stuff 10% super
fantastic ideas 4% super crazy huge
stuff 1% stuff I can't talk about now
but trust me of super great nice boobs
by the way
[Applause]
Stephen Baldwin income Andy Richter what
49% salary at Conan 27% residuals from
Conan 24% kickback from Conan for
laughing at literally anything that was
a pie charts
and finally Nicholas Cage 30% residuals
from national treasure
30% residuals from national treasure to
12% residuals from gone in 60 seconds 7%
residuals from diaper forest 3 3 percent
residuals from hooch from the spank man
2 percent residuals from paging doctor
pretzel 1% residuals from dinosaur
dance-party 1% residuals from professor
not showing the temple cheese 1%
potentials from hammer flinches
pan-flute 1% residuals from find those
pancakes represent residuals from return
to chihuahua co weapon second tentacles
from case off for I got the wrong face
versed with some bactine in jet
represent magicians from - I see high
passes several films together Cuban Jew
Boogaloo white cause every gentlest
embark party 3d what does that residuals
from Holiday Inn Express the movie 1
cent residuals from zombie stay-at-home
dad went to st. residuals from Ghost
Rider 3 mr. bean for residuals from
journey to diary Island 1% residuals
from escape from diarrhoea 1% residuals
from dangerous toilet to the flushing
Wow
I didn't know there was that new powers
yeah
[Applause]
you